PROFESSOR: Let me do a
little exercise using still
this manipulation.
And I'll confirm
the way we think
about expectations values.
So, suppose exercise.
Suppose you have indeed that
psi is equal to alpha i psi i.
Compute the expectation value
of Q in the state of psi.
Precisely, the expectation
value of this operator
we've been talking
about on the state.
So this is equal to the
integral dx psi star Q psi.
And now I have to
put two sums before.
And go a little fast here.
dx sum over i alpha i psi i
star Q sum over j alpha j psi j.
No star.
This is equal to sum over i
sum over j alpha i star alpha j
integral dx psi i star Q psi j.
But Q psi j is
equal to qj psi j.
Therefore, this whole
thing is equal to qj
times the integral dx
of psi i star psi j,
which is qj delta ij.
So here we go.
It's equal to sum
over i, sum over j,
alpha i star alpha
j, qj delta ij, which
is equal to the sum over i.
The j's disappear.
And this is alpha i squared qi.
That's it.
OK.
Now you're supposed to
look at this and say, yay.
Now why is that?
Look.
How did we define
expectation values?
We defined it as the sum of
the value times the probability
that this value have.
It's for a random variable.
So here our random variable is
the result of the measurement.
And what are the
possible values?
qi's.
And what are the probabilities
that they have Pi?
OK.
So the expectation value
of q should be that,
should be the sum of
the possible values
times their probabilities, and
that's what the system gives.
This is how we defined
expectation value of x.
Even though it's
expectation value of P.
And it all comes from
the measurement postulate
and the definition.
Now, this definition and
the measurement postulate
just shows that this
is what we expect.
This is the result of
the expectation value.
OK.
I think I have a nice example.
I don't know if I
want to go into all
the detail of these
things, but they illustrate
things in a nice way.
So let's try to do it.
So here it is.
It's a physical example.
This is a nice concrete example
because things work out.
So I think we'll
actually illustrate
some physical points.
Example.
Particle on a circle.
x 0 to L. Maybe you haven't
seen a circle described by that,
but you take the x-axis,
and you say yes, the circle
is 0 to L. L and 0.
And the way you think
of it is that this point
is identified with this point.
If you have a line and you
identify the two endpoints,
that's called a circle.
It's in the sense of topology.
A circle as the set of points
equidistant to a center
is a geometric description
of a round circle.
But this, topologically
speaking, anything
that is closed is
topologically a circle.
We think of a circle
as this, physically,
or it could be a curved line
that makes it into a circle.
But it's not important.
Let's consider a free
particle on a circle,
and suppose the circle has
an end L. So x belongs here.
And here is the wave
function, psi equals 2 over L,
1 over square root
of 3 sine of 2 pi
x over L, plus 2 over square
root of 3 cosine 6 pi x over L.
This is the wave function of
your particle on a circle.
At some time, time equals
0, it's a free particle.
No potential.
And it lives in the
circle, and these functions
are kind of interesting.
You see, if you
live on the circle
you would want to emphasize
the fact that this point 0 is
the same as the point L,
so you should have that psi
and L must be equal to psi at 0.
It's a circle, after
all, it's the same point.
And therefore for 0 or
for L, the difference here
is 0 or 2 pi, and the
sine is the same thing.
And 0, when x equals 0, and 6
pi, so that's also periodic,
and it's fine.
It's a good wave
function result.
The question is,
for this problem,
what are, if you measure
momentum, measure momentum,
what are the possible values
and their probabilities?
Probabilities.
So you decide to measure
momentum of this particle.
What can you get?
OK.
It looks a little nontrivial,
and it is a little nontrivial.
Momentum.
So I must sort of find
the momentum eigenstates.
Momentum eigenstates, they are
those infinite plane waves,
e to the ikx, that we
could never normalize.
Because you square it, it's 1,
and the integral over all space
is infinite.
So are we heading
for disaster here?
No.
Because it lives
in a finite space.
Yes, you have a question?
STUDENT: Should it be a wave
function [INAUDIBLE] complex?
Because right now, it just
looks like it's a real value.
And we can't [INAUDIBLE]
real wave functions, can we?
PROFESSOR: Well, it is the
wave function at time equals 0.
So the time
derivative would have
to bring in complex things.
So you can have a
wave function that
is 0, that is real at
some particular time.
Like, any wave function psi of
x e to the minus iEt over h bar
is a typical wave function.
And then at time equal
0 it may be real.
It cannot be real forever.
So you cannot assume it's real.
But at some particular
times it could be real.
Very good question.
The other thing you
might say, look, this
is too real to have momentum.
Momentum has to do with waves.
That's probably not
a reliable argument.
OK, so, where do
we go from here?
Well, let's try to find
the momentum eigenstates.
They should be things
like that, exponentials.
So how could they look?
Well, e to the 2 pi i, maybe.
What else?
x, there should be an
x for a momentum thing.
Now there should
be no units here,
so there better be an L here.
And now I could put, maybe,
well the 2 maybe was--
why did I think of
the 2 or the pi?
Well, for convenience.
But let's see what.
Suppose you have
a number m here.
Then the good thing about this
is that when x is equal to 0,
there is some number here,
but when x is equal to L,
it's a multiple of e to the
2 pi i, so that's periodic.
So this does satisfy, I
claim, it's the only way
if m is any integer.
So it goes from minus
infinity to infinity.
Those things are periodic.
They satisfy psi.
Actually they satisfy psi of
x plus L is equal to psi of x.
OK.
That seems to be something that
could be a momentum eigenstate.
And then I have to normalize it.
Well, if I square
it and integrate it.
If I square it then the
phase cancels, so you get 1.
If you integrate it
you get L. If you put 1
over the square root of L, when
you square it and integrate,
you will get 1.
So here it is.
Psi m's of x are going to
be defined to be this thing.
And I claim these things
are momentum eigenstates.
In fact, what is the
value of the momentum?
Well, you calculate h
bar over i d dx on psi m.
And you get what?
You get 2 pi m over L
times h bar times psi.
The h bar is there, the i
cancels, and everything then
multiplies, the x falls down.
So this is the
state with momentum
P equals to h bar 2 pi m over L.
OK.
Actually, doing that, we've
done the most difficult part
of the problem.
You've found the
momentum eigenfunctions.
So now the rest of the thing
is to rewrite this in terms
of this kind of objects.
I'll do it in a second.
Maybe I'll leave a
little space there
and you can check
the algebra, and you
can see it in the notes.
But you know what
you're supposed to do.
A sine of x is e to the ix minus
is e to the minus ix over 2i.
So you'd get these things
converted to exponentials.
The cosine of x is
equal to e to the ix
plus e to the minus ix over 2.
So if you do that with
those things, look.
What the sine of 2 pi
x going to give you?
It's going to give you some
exponentials of 2 pi ix over L.
So suppose that m equals 1.
And m Equals minus 1.
And this will give you m
equals 3, 3 times 2 is 6.
And m equal minus 3.
So I claim, after some work,
and you could try to do it.
I think it would
be a nice exercise.
Psi is equal square
root of 2 over 3,
1 over 2 i psi 1 minus square
root of 2 over 3, 1 over 2i psi
minus 1 plus 1 over
square root of 3 psi 3,
plus 1 over square
root of 3 psi minus 3.
And it should give
you some satisfaction
to see something like that.
You're now seeing
the wave function
written as a superposition
of momentum eigenstates.
This theorem came through.
In this case, as a
particle in the circle,
the statement is that
the eigenfunctions
are the exponentials, and
it's Fourier's theorem.
Again, for a series.
So finally, here is the answer.
So psi 1, we can measure psi 1.
What is the momentum of psi 1?
So here are p values.
And probabilities.
The first value, psi 1, the
momentum is 2 pi h bar over L.
So 2 pi h bar over L. And
what is its probability?
It's this whole number squared.
So square root of 2/3,
1 over 2i squared.
So how much is that?
It's 2/3 times 1/4.
2/3 times 1/4, which is 1/6.
And the other value that you
can get is minus this one,
so minus 2 pi h bar over L.
This minus doesn't matter,
probability also 1/6.
The next one is with 3.
So you can get 2, 6
pi, 6 pi h bar over L,
with probability
square of this, 1/3.
And minus 6 pi h bar over
L with probability 1/3.
Happily our
probabilities add up.
So there you go.
That's the theorem expressed
in a very clear example.
We had a wave function.
You wrote it as a sum of
four momentum eigenstates.
And now you know, if
you do a measurement,
what are the possible
values of the momentum.
This should have
been probably 1/6.
You can do anything you want.